roma e aí galera assistir o canal tudo
bem com você e aí galera que aceite meu
canal tudo bem com você e nem está ótimo
estou ótimo em olha que beleza não está
melhor que o gripado vivendo à base de
florinda tahuana imóvel merda ataca uma
palavra que já leva com nojenta não tem
que falar catarro lembrar de pouco amor
eu quero ter um cargo no fim da sessão
decorria ela aí pra [ __ ] de porto
velho lembra no dia 26 de maio tem show
aí no talismã 21 às sete e meia da noite
com os ingressos o dia 27 tem uma está a
amazonas dia 28 de maio rio branco acre
dia 29 de maio cruzeiro do sul acre como
ingresso nesse site que está aparecendo
aqui na tela o primeiro link da
descrição do vídeo é nóis é eu fui você
levasse x-men apocalipse pintura que o
ex meia são os mutantes só que são
mutantes como mutantes mesmo em força
efeitos especiais 3d nativo os mutantes
caminhos do coração não é esse filme
mostra tipo começo começo das coisas do
tipo 1940 xuxa nova iguaçu era lá que eu
acho muito bacana que é o scott está a
acertar na privada dele a 18 diz aí
aquele raio superman é bem do banheiro
do hotel pcm em que cagada medronho e
aquela coisa vermelha saindo olho no
cargo já vi sair sangue alguém bota
força pra galera pelo coo na primeira
vez que ele sai do olho ou cagada
desgraçada e por mostrar a luta do anjo
a de um cara que é mutante que tem a
zaga enquanto noturno noturno aquele
fácil é feito aqui sabe fazer fib o
patrão aqui é especial que viu hoje você
fazer hoje também a versão
tudo é esse é hoje que eu consegui sair
a mostra o magneto também o magnata e
trabalha na serraria uma porrada na
globe torneio mas que faz por lá o que é
belo com uma cinta mostrar quando era
bom em tudo isso é que os apps - fosse
os mutantes caminhos do coração ia
trabalhar por uma madeireira amar
moraria e mostra alguns chegando à casa
dos f-16 next x6 paixão de sanduíches e
hambúrgueres patrão e b1 x men e um x
gana legais com gelo e limão que ele
mostre se matriculando as apanhou servir
como escola persegue as pessoas você nem
você sendo é o mesmo você se livra da
escola em você é obrigado a escola vai
buscar o seu você tiver professam a
professora marta que é isso eu sou um ex
membro tenho poderes ou eu sei
desaparecer e aparecer aí é pois apareça
amanhã que concedeu efeito até uma cena
que tem uma pirâmide o pessoal tem
invocar os ataques sempre assim todo o
filme assim o gol porque está morta que
é do mal mas o pessoal quer reviver essa
coisa todo filme é isso não deixa lá que
é o pessoal um esse satanás vivos aí eu
recrutando a galera pega o anjo que era
saúde e deixei quase de ferro quase
normal
o anjo azul de fé ele vai melhorando a
tempestade na nora tempestade era só um
mas sim a ele melhor é melhor haver a
tempestade meia hora e os mutantes nessa
época são perseguidas pessoa quer matar
os cargos têm poder é sempre assim
quando a pessoa tem alguma coisa de boa
da pessoa tem alguma coisa a mais que
ela as outras pessoas que não tenha fica
puto de raiva é o motorzinho de merda eu
acho esse comentário do instagram luta
em mutantes de merda do olho no teu olho
onde poder de olho vermelho de merda eu
então casal de multan ela atacou está
com ele só porque ele é um ex nela feita
é interesseira até um é interessante ela
está com ele é só porque teu olho
vermelho até a mega ultra blaster
explosão na casa dos ex bbbs que todo
mundo vai morrer e está todo mundo
preparado mega explosão tipo ah tô me
você fez o que todo mundo vai morrer já
faz assim a esposa ou sony 3d onde vai
matar o cinema todo em todo mundo
conhece é que aparece o pietro o cara
mais rápido do ex-iêmen o filho do
magnata o bicho do valor a gente corre
muito mas as pessoas com paradinha tipo
assim ele chega
se tivesse alguém a lei
ele salva todo mundo da casa para ser
rápido é [ __ ] viu agora também já em
relação ao negócio eo amor pode botar
fogo no rabo terra bom tempo divertir eu
botei onde vem a água seja botou o cara
do mal fica tentando convencer o
professor xavier a ficar do lado deles
também ele fica só falando cara vai ser
melhor pra você você vai se sentir bem a
sua vida vai melhorar tipo aquela pessoa
fica tentando te convence a vender
natura tem hora que aparecem antigo
parece envolver em arco sem nos olhos
irmãos civil aparece sangue mais do que
a menstruação de dez mulheres juntas ou
vêem com sangue nos olhos
o secop parece a perder o governo vai
tomar tal ciclope e jean grey aparece
danã o juiz mulher [ __ ] é k o cara para
na hora
mulher é [ __ ] ela parou o carro com
poderes de telepatia mulher [ __ ] porque
mulher inteligente esse poder só foi pra
ela porque ela é mulher ela viu o cara
matando todo mundo ela chegou por
telepatia e parou de responder fosse pra
onde que queria fazer e acertar o
wolverine é jogar dele começa agora
embora ainda mais aposta aposta quem
será que o wolverine vai matar dessa vez
em 300 reais também estão apostando
wolverine terá show na vila gigante
aquela pergunta se você sabe pilotar a
nave o cara eu acho que eu sei vamos lá
aí o cara entra pega nos controle povoa
com a nave de foto ex membro da sanifill
e todo mundo sabe pilotar um na'vi eu
tirar a carteira fase na baliza com o
pop 6/1 cone ometto qo no chão essa
pilotar naves é é voluntário pessoal bem
contra o mal lugar vai só o bagaço caem
os prédios pedaços rua esburacada tipo
brasil era melhor filme create a new
augusta apresentar-se com namorada vamos
devolver watson amor não posso usar
pequenas onde estão assim o avião fosse
matar toda cinema aí eu abri era só oi
mesmo de bosta mesmo se você tiver
gostar desse vídeo já sabe fazer clique
em gostei aqui no youtube momento aqui
embaixo você assistir o filme ou não se
você vai assistir o que você achou desse
vídeo volta lá no facebook eu postei
vídeo novo os x men assistir-se que
clique em curtir marca seus amigos que
já assistiram o filme ou não assistirão
ainda vão achar muito engraçado quando
fosse um filme ou lembrado que eu falei
marcas nos comentários e escreve o canal
você nunca
em um vídeo novo muito obrigado por tudo
porque assisti esse vídeo até aqui um
beijão é nós e b e pr pé
valeu que sou engenheiro